l'enfant a désormais des droits affirmé
est protégé par la communauté des
nations
l'assemblée générale de l'onu a adopté
aujourd'hui après dix ans de travaux une
première convention sur les droits de
l'enfant principale menace la guerre et
l'exploitation dans le travail and gas
burget aux abords de bangkok
voici l'univers de centaines d'enfants
un immense dépotoir partie des campagnes
surpeuplée sans ressources
ils viennent chercher aux confins des
grandes villes de quoi travailler et
nourrir leurs familles toute leur
enfance ici à piocher les ordures en
quête d'objets en plastique en verre
qu'ils revendront au kilo
comme ils sont aujourd'hui 100 millions
d'enfants dans le monde moins de 15 ans
et un travail qui ressemble plus à de l'
esclavage des enfants à qui l'on demande
d'être adulte pour une bouchée de pain
ou pour une guerre ces adolescents
iranien prisonniers dans les camps
d'irakiens ses enfants encore victime
des armes chimiques du même conflit
deux siècles après la déclaration des
droits de l'homme sont enfin reconnus
les droits de l'enfant mais jusqu'où
seront ils respectés
les conventions sont un moyen pour
aboutir à corriger des injustices
elles ne suffisent pas à elle seule à y
parvenir il faut évidemment que la
volonté gouvernementale s'ajoute à cela
dans certaines circonstances lorsque
j'étais un représentant de l'unicef en
charge sur le terrain de faire respecter
les droits des enfants d'assurer leur
protection lors développement si jamais
j'avais eu la convention des droits de
l'enfant derrière moi pour appuyer
certaines de mes dix initiatives sûr
d'être infiniment plus facile le droit à
un nom à une nationalité le droit aussi
à l'éducation le droit à être protégé de
l'exploitation des violences morales ou
physiques avant tout le droit de rester
un enfant
je